once you've learned how to parse JSON
data it's pretty straightforward to be
able to parse the rest of the fields
that we need since this isn't a course
on Java or JSON we're going to provide
you with the parsing code in the gist
below and this is what the gist looks
like there are three helper methods the
first is for formatting dates the second
is for rounding temperatures the third
is for turning a forecast JSON string
into an array of forecasts this method
also handles associating a date with
each forecast entry we start with a
current date and we increment one for
each successive day notice that we also
use Julian dates which is the number of
days that have passed since the
beginning of the Julian period more
information is an instructor notes below
but it's how will consistently deal with
dates in our app that way when comparing
dates we don't have to worry about
taking into account time zones or
daylight savings time update the
fetchweathertask to use these helper
functions and the do and background
method should return a string array of
forecasts you can log the output to
check that the array is correct the
format of one days forecast should look
like this